ok nächste frage ist wirklich richtig
krass eigentlich aber macht auch immer
weil wir da ehrliche antworten geben
können und vor allem gestern haben mit
dem andere youtuber darüber geredet
haben und zwar ist es ich habe noch nie
einen fan gespielt und willkommen zu
einem neuen video leute im heutigen
video wird jemand dazu stoßen wir alle
kennen es ist der fucking erfinder von
der goldgräber zwei der erfinder von
fahrkarten kontrolliert davon dieses
logistische ablauf und die spiele heute
haben wir schon gesehen ich hab noch nie
dafür haben wir selbstständig die karten
zu haben aber die karten ich habe mich
wiederholt dann haben wir natürlich
einmal die karte ich habe noch nie
selbstverständlich die bekomme ich und
wir haben die karte ich habe noch nie
dieses für dich da musst du dir gemacht
ich danke mir passt aber besser zu dir
ist ja auch nichts damit zu tun dass
seine druckerpatronen lehrerwohnung
erste daneben fällt es einfach noch mal
das nachzeichnen weil das sie darüber
wissen und klaus ich habe noch nie sehr
gut läuft ist kein normales ich habe
noch nie
ex tsg hatte ihr dumm
das ist ein normales erklärter feind
dazu gestellten fragen sind noch packen
einfach der erste von irgendwas count
der haitianer ins netz ich wollte
nämlich noch nie gehört die seite ich
habe ja noch nie zum weinen gebracht
okay das nur so ganz gelang 3 2 1 ich
habe auch schon wann der diskussion
ich habe ja schon tausend mal
erschrocken und dann zwei jahren arbeit
hat ständig neuer story ein beispiel
unbedingt zusammen auf der couch oder
solche aktion zu war also nicht mal
unbedingt lauter als sohnemann fünf
sekunden später sind die tränen in den
augen und heinz ahlers gutes beispiel
leute wissen in meinem auto gefahren ich
war am steuer ist auch ein bisschen
später nacht auf einmal muss ich
genießen ich nichts halt ein anders mal
ein bisschen lauter vielleicht auf
einmal ich nie so kommt von der rhythmus
asiana aufgewartet dazu fliegt mal nicht
so erschrocken dass er zuweilen dem
moment klar nächste nummer ich habe mir
noch nie eine lehrerin nackt vorgestellt
dazu muss ich ganz klar sagt du hast du
dir immer eine attraktive lehrerin ich
hatte man die attraktive lehrerin dicker
du warst auch mal 13 13 abgeben
ich bin 21 weist das für mich
abgeleitete her aber ich habe mich nicht
als möglichst niedriger semester
klingenfuß haben als kursleiter und zwar
näher
ja ich bin mir selber also auf jeden
fall mal eine sport lisboa okay ich
würde es aus dem stegreif sagen bestimmt
drei lehrerinnen von mir nächstes werk
von jahren sind lose ich habe noch nie
daran gedacht dass eine minderjährige
guide ist jetzt hier so was darunter ist
sehr vieles möglich gerade weil das
tablet auf sich hat nein 321 euro
arbeitet auch männer oder als feurig was
da hatte ich noch nie
als du 18 bist waren alle mädels wie
interessant fand ist ja ok aber du hast
doch selbst ich habe noch nie hoch
gehalten
ja okay gibt es aber so ein
altersunterschied von 18 17 ist ja auch
viel 45 jahre altersunterschied sind
okay ein stück ein
das werde ich nicht okay nächste frage
ist wirklich richtig krass eigentlich
die zuzustellen auch eine bio rhein zu
nehmen
das wird wahrscheinlich die wenigsten so
machen aber macht es einfacher weil wir
da ehrliche antworten geben können und
vor den gästen haben mit dem anderen
bücher darüber geredet haben und zwar
ist es ich habe noch nie einen geplant
also gefragte leute ihr wisst alle was
geplant in diesem kontext bedeuten so
hört dass man so richtig sind die linie
runter rennen und den ball schön
anschneidet dass er in rain köpfen kann
mit den fans fußball spielt also darum
geht dann würde ich einfach sagen
leute wir haben wirklich gestern abend
mit einem youtuber darüber geredet und
event wie sieht dieser youtube auch
dieses video hat gemeint er schaut meine
videos der hat natürlich gesagt ja
selbst also schon auf jeden fall mal
drei oder so und ich habe wieder
natürlich vorrang habe gesagt sogar 16
habe ich keinen bock hat über das thema
zu reden aber max anderen sind natürlich
die antwort nein das ist ultra hat oder
weil ich so ein ungleiches verhältnis
jetzt ein richtiger fan ist ja ja also
fan wirklich also jetzt ein richtiger
nein man die gar nicht wie die das
machen
das motto alles was von dieser folge ich
habe noch nie zusammen mit überzahl
ergibt zusammen mit ägypten dank fürs
zuschauen hier fällt mir so nicht
vorgestellt
hier könnte man kalkulieren ihr kommt
jetzt in einem neuen fall dass das
geschenk das gerne abgeschafft fordert
du willst einen like gibt